if you follow the sport pages you may  have noticed a recent picture of Miss  Marilyn Monroe taken with the Pittsburgh  pirate baseball team a Louisville Sports  Editors summed it up when he said it's  the best the Pirates have looked since  before they blew the 1927 World Series  to present the award for sound recording  Miss Marilyn Monroe  because it is such a highly cooperative  enterprise this award is not given to an  individual it goes to a sound recording  Department those nominated all All About  Eve  20th Century Fox Cinderella  Walt Disney Productions RKO radio Luiza  universal international our very own  Samuel Goldwyn productions RKO radio and  trio Jane AuthorRank Sydney rock  sparrowmon British the envelope please  the winner All About Eve the sound  apartment of 20 Century Fox has  previously won three awards for sound  recording willkommen 1941 enterprises  12 o'clock high  49  Thomas Thomas team Wilton accepted the  award for 20th Century Fox Studios sound  apart